what are your thoughts when you see a
musk being out of Kevin McCarthy event
and Kevin McCarthy is one of the most
hated guys on the left
well you know I don't have a problem
with it to be honest with you uh I think
you gotta listen to All Points of View
and Elon Musk is an important voice
um
you know particularly since he may at
some point on Twitter
so I don't think it's uh necessarily A
Bad Thing to cultivate a relationship
with them I don't agree with a lot of
the stuff that he does or says uh but
that doesn't mean that we shouldn't keep
the communications open I agree and I I
fully agree with you there the the
question the challenge becomes
if the nominee is a trump and the two of
them had a back and forth on Twitter
where he calls him another [ __ ]
artist and then he comes out and says
look I think we should just kind of move
away from politics and I think the
moment your age starts with number seven
you shouldn't run anymore and they had
that back and forth how this is going to
look if the nominee is Trump would musk
support a trump if he is the nominee or
would he go the other side
and I don't know that would be pretty
interesting to see what happens there it
would be interesting but but that's one
of the reasons that I think it's
important to to keep the channels of
communication open you said that earlier
yeah the dialogue is so vitally
important but what's the difference
between a musk sitting down with the
Kevin McCarthy you know number one guy
in the in in the house and a
um and a gate sitting down with Joe
mancha isn't that exactly the same thing
a billionaire speaking with a major
political figure that's exactly that's
exactly why I brought the support the
story right afterwards the only
difference is is the following this is
the only difference between the two
whose motives do you trust more do you
trust Bill Gates's motives or do you
trust Elon musk's motives that's the
decision you gotta make because you know
like let's just say if somebody is
trying to judge you
and they say who's an atoms here they
say well Patrick Davis and Adam's here
if a person doesn't trust Patrick they
may say I don't want Patrick but they've
been in Adam's ear right and so let me
tell you who's in that guy's ear so you
have to sit there and say would you
rather have an Elon Musk in someone's
ear or Bill Gates in someone's ear the
voter has to decide that because both of
them are in the top five most powerful
people in the world when it comes down
to money you can only add a couple other
names to that list you can ask Bezos and
maybe a couple other guys but they're
both in the top five at any given moment
so who do you trust more Gates or Musk
and by the way they've got some some
internal beef themselves right who do
you trust more gates from us who do you
who do you think has more of a best
interest for America between the two uh
personally I would come down on the musk
side okay yeah and what's the what's the
the biggest reason why
uh because you already said that you're
not a big fan of musk right right but
because of his concern about freedom of
speech
and uh like I said I don't agree with
them on everything but I think freedom
of speech is such a vital part of who we
are as a nation and what's your do you
have a beef with Bill Gates is there
something about Bill Gates you're like I
don't really uh like what he's doing
with that thing what would that be well
I I think his uh tremendous emphasis on
the climate
uh above everything else is problematic
for me what do you think his motive is
with their speculation
uh I think he
kneels at the altar of climate like so
many others on the left and because of
that they believed themselves to be
righteous and when they believe
themselves to be righteous anybody who
opposes them
uh you know you can lie to them you can
do anything you want to them
and uh I I don't
agree with that kind of philosophy so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]